and to our other top story tonight the
city's largest public road Public Works
project ever is supposed to be completed
here in just a few months and Denise the
department says it's even a bit ahead of
schedule but by the end it'll be three
years of construction a lot of headaches
for locals and businesses Ryan Matthey
joins us live now from the Boulevard
near the straat hotel with an update on
the date for it to be all wrapped up
Brian
yeah Denise and Brian the city says it's
110 million dollars all in the name of
Public Safety what we're standing on
right now it's a platform part of this
project it's to get the perfect selfie
with the Las Vegas arches there because
people instead are jumping in the middle
of the street to get that photo Beyond
this platform wider sidewalks added
Center dividers and a whole lot more
underground work but businesses along it
they say damage has already been done
the Las Vegas Boulevard Improvement
project starting in April 2020 and
ending hopefully in April 2023. we're
almost there we can see the light Las
Vegas engineering project manager
Cassandra Watson mihelzic oversees it
all construction from Sahara to Stuart
that's replacing decades-old underground
utilities and adding safety features for
pedestrians 10 to 15 feet wide sidewalks
repaved curbs new traffic signals and
access to bus stops along with
beautification like 200 new trees and
making these Showgirls even taller than
before as you see they have cons
everywhere they don't understand but
with positives come negatives Felix
Ariano says a quarter of his customer
base has stopped coming to his
Venezuelan restaurant since this started
the majority of the guests are tourists
so if they're not familiar with the area
they're going to have trouble finding us
with all the construction and for Eric
booksa assistant general manager for the
downtown Grand Hotel and Casino head
counts are down 30 percent with all the
construction we understand that it's
going to be an impact but I think
overall at the end of the day it's going
to be a great project that's going to
bring a lot more people downtown the
noise from the construction and just the
dust and the mess it's going to make our
area look a lot cleaner and more
inviting for guests to come down and
visit us but everything takes takes time
you know I understand but it is they
still breaking the street and I don't
understand why
now that project manager says the city
works with businesses to minimize that
customer impact she also adds that a
majority of the work is already done
what's left now she calls the finishing
touches reporting live on the Las Vegas
Boulevard near the Strat Hotel Ryan
Matthey a news now